[MUSIC PLAYING]
JULIAN SAYARER: Thanks
very much, guys.
Thanks very much for
the introduction.
Yeah, so I'm coming from a
background in political science
but at a young age
really started cycling.
Essentially, I grew up
in the Midlands of the UK
in a quite sort of
post-industrial, slightly
depressed town with
not a lot going on.
I had my bicycle
and loved the way
that it could take
me out of that town.
After university, I
cycled to Istanbul
and fell in love
with the fact that I
could cross a
continent in a month
with only my legs
and my bicycle.
And in Istanbul, I discovered
that the world record
for a circumnavigation
by bicycle
was being broken
in this very kind
of corporate-backed attempt that
was sort of at odds with all
that I'd found travel
by bicycle to be.
And so I set out to
break that record.
And this sort of
led me to the genre,
if you like, of politics
at roadsides, basically.
And as John says, the book
that I'm talking about today
is "Interstate," from the
United States, which is actually
more of a hitchhiking book.
There are some kind
of correlations
or contrasts between travel by
bike and hitchhiking in the US,
which I'll come on to.
And having cycled 6,000
miles across the US
and then hitchhiked
maybe 4,000 miles,
it's kind of different
perspectives on that country,
and that you find,
again, at the roadsides.
And the title of
"Interstate" was
kind of no coincidence
in that respect.
Starting out, then, at
the beginning of the trip,
which began in New York
City, as we can see.
An image we're all
pretty familiar with.
And I'd gone there to work
on a documentary project,
but that year failed
to materialize.
And interestingly enough,
that was taking a boat
down the Hudson River from
the Adirondack Mountains
to Manhattan.
The boat was made from
rubbish that was found
on the streets of the city.
And the idea was to
take it to the source
of the river in nature and
return to the metropolis.
And so that's another kind
of interesting element
that came into my
relationship with the US
and with New York State.
And that diversity that
you see in the population,
as soon as you leave the hubs
of airport terminal to airport
terminal, or office
to office, when
you go through the space
between those places,
whether that's on the road, or
wherever that's off the road,
or at the roadside hitchhiking,
or along the river, that
doesn't have the
same-- the geographies
that don't have the same kind
of regard for place as the very
charted existences that
we as humans often lead
in our ways of going between
countries, around the country,
and between cities.
The book begins in New York.
And actually, oddly enough,
with today being local elections
in London, I was out canvassing
with a friend for the de Blasio
campaign, Bill de
Blasio, who I think
got elected in 2013 with
a majority of about 70%
on a very low voter turnout.
And in some ways, that kind of
frames the start of the book,
because you see this kind of
metropolitan elite, or elite,
question mark.
And this bubble
existence of Brooklyn
with the sourdough bread
and the spinach and salmon
and the coffee and all of the
things that we know and love
and like.
Electing this apparently
progressive politician
in the same way that London
would have elected Sadiq Kahn,
or we see the rising
popularity of Jeremy Corbyn.
And you see this optimism for
the future and progressive
ideals.
And then crossing over the
Brooklyn Bridge into Manhattan
and then the George Washington
Bridge out of Manhattan
into New Jersey--
I don't mean-- hopefully there's
no one from New Jersey here,
but I don't want to do
that thing of presenting
New Jersey as the
frontiers of the badlands.
I really like New Jersey.
Some of my best friends
are from New Jersey--
and taking their
shot on the way out.
And then you land
on the other side
into this less controlled
existence where you're not sure
exactly where you're going
and what's happening next.
Hitchhiking-- the sign,
as you can imagine,
is quite important when
you're hitchhiking.
I headed towards Ohio,
and my first destination
that I had vaguely
in mind was Columbus.
So for that, I needed to
go through New Jersey,
Pennsylvania.
Discovered-- at
the time, I didn't
know that Pennsylvania
was called the wide state,
but it certainly made
sense after a while.
And I ended up cheating a
little bit on the hitchhiking.
That was the only time.
And I got a Greyhound for
a couple of hundred miles
to get to Columbus
just to get me moving.
The sign and the
nature of standing
at the roadsides in the US is
kind of a particular thing.
I think the first
sign that I had
and I held up just said "west."
The project in the
US, in New York,
had fallen through
for that year.
So I was there in New
York with no real plans,
having rented out
my room in Dalston.
And so thinking, well, I
should really go to California
and hitchhike there.
And it seemed like a
sensible enough thing to do.
And I started with my
very enigmatic, evocative
"west" sign and then realized
that nobody was picking me up.
So then I started adding
more words to it, like Ohio,
then please.
And suddenly you realize that
your very simple looking sign
that you really want to
catch the driver's attention
is suddenly looking
quite cluttered.
So you get a new bit of
cardboard and you start again.
And it's kind of an
iteration of that
again and again until you find
something that seems to work.
I remember this sign with Ohio.
A guy who picked me
up and gave me a ride
said, well, you
were going to Ohio,
and I'm going there next week.
So I thought I'd pick you up.
And then after that
I thought, OK, I'm
always going to put
a place name on it.
And it was interesting
that in the United States,
you have so many
people just standing
at roadsides just moving.
And you have so many people
in the-- it's a very migratory
culture, I think, the States.
There's a strong kind
of notion of traveling
within your country,
seeing your country.
And there are a lot of
people at those roadsides.
I think were they
in Europe possibly
wouldn't have fallen so far
out of the bottom of society.
Some of them, I think, might
be getting professional help.
I spoke to a guy in
New Mexico who was--
he'd lost the front of his teeth
to presumably class-A drugs
and smoking them.
And he told me that he'd just
buried his mother in Texas,
and this was all within
the first two minutes
of meeting him.
And so you kind of
get to understand
why people are driving
straight by you at the roadside
and not picking you up.
So actually, writing a
destination on your sign
came to feel like a
statement of intention
and a statement of purpose.
And I found that it
got me more lifts.
There was also things about how
I would stand at the roadside.
Sometimes you'd
just sort of lazily
be there like that
with your thumb out,
and then realize you're
not getting any lifts.
So you think, maybe I should
put more effort into this
and be a bit more upright.
Sometimes I'd kind of be zipped
right up because it was cold.
And then I thought,
well, maybe that
looks a little bit
robotic and inhuman,
so you unzip and
relax a little bit.
And again, with these hours
and hours at the roadside,
you're just slowly trying
to figure out, actually,
what is going to work?
What is going to get
one of these cars
to stop and pick me up?
And when you're
actually in the car,
it's an interesting experience.
Has anyone hitchhiked
here before?
Oh, cool.
That's a really
great percentage.
Normally, when I
do a talk about it,
it's probably about one
or two hands at most.
AUDIENCE: I've hitchhiked
out of Desperation
It wasn't intention.
JULIAN SAYARER: Yeah?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: But if could have--
JULIAN SAYARER: Did it work?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
In Texas.
JULIAN SAYARER: Oh, Texas is
a great place to hitchhike,
but Texas isn't necessarily the
best place to try and cycle.
Because every time you stop at
the roadside with your map--
in the days when they're
actually made of paper--
and someone pulls in
with a pickup saying,
we can put your bike in
the back if you like.
No, I'm doing it for fun.
And then, you're sure?
So yeah.
But yeah, the
experience of it, where
you're kind of strangers,
complete strangers,
and then placed into this
automobile confessional booth
almost, because you've
got to keep one another's
company for whatever
amount of time you will.
And that's a finite
amount of time.
And you don't know the
person, but at the same time,
you need to talk
about something.
And so the tendency is to
talk about the things that
actually matter.
You talk about, well,
why are you doing this?
And it's like, well, there's a
project that's fallen through,
and I thought I'd
go to California.
Where are you driving?
Well, I'm driving
home to visit my kids.
Me and the wife separated.
Or I'm driving home from work.
I don't much like it.
So in this sort of
automotive 21st century
environment of the car, or 20th
century, I'd say, motor car,
you end up talking quite
quickly about the things that
actually matter.
And in a world where
increasingly communication
pathways and the
objects, the people
that we are actually
communicating with
are ever more controlled.
And perhaps we
become ever more wary
of leaving those
controlled pathways.
The random encounter
of "I've got the trust
to be standing at a roadside
and requesting a lift,
and you've got the random
trust to pull in and say,
here, I'm going to
give you one" gives you
that sort of connection
just for a short time.
And it kind of--
yeah, it kind of brings
out a certain bond
between people who actually
might be very different.
They might be Republican voters.
They might be Democrat voters.
They might be immigrants.
They might identify as being
settlers from the first Scots
that went over to the US.
But they've all got
the idea to pick up
this stranger at the roadside.
And this is an older
photo, actually,
and goes back to the
point I touched on earlier
of the differences between
cycling and hitchhiking
in the United States.
This guy is Super
Dave, as he went known.
This is from 2009
when I was cycling
the West Coast of California.
And he had two trailers here.
He had a dog that
ran along with him.
He had a story, as everyone
traveling the US has a story.
His destination on the
roadside was basically
to get down to Santa Barbara.
He was from Washington.
And Washington State, of
course, has a very cold winter.
So he was moving
south to get warm
for winter, which is a fairly
timeless and distressingly
common migration within the US.
I met another guy
on that same trip
who was from Montana,
which is, of course,
also bitterly cold winters.
And he was cycling down
into New Mexico for winter
just to stay warm.
So again, you have
this hard reality
of life for tens or hundreds of
thousands or millions of people
in the richest
country in the world.
But nevertheless,
at all times kind
of connected to this
eternally optimistic spirit.
These guys living by bicycle.
I remember Mike, the
guy from Montana,
telling me that he was
all right on the bike,
because he could see
the stars at night.
And if he could see
the stars at night,
he knew that Jesus was
watching out for him.
And that same sort of good
feeling that the guys on bikes
have out there seems to
get reflected back at it
by the US population.
And the amount of
money, for example,
that I was given, having
never once asked for it,
while cycling across the
US was unfathomable to me.
I'd had bicycle repairs
that needed doing
and strangers fronting
up $100 because they
wanted to pay for them.
I had a family from
South Carolina who
took me in and paid for
another set of repairs
and wanted to set me off with
$100 to put me on my way.
I rode 300 miles
in one long stretch
to get to New York
in time for a friend,
and crossing into Delaware had
a woman wind down the car window
and say, you're doing
something amazing here,
and just pass out $10 for me.
Well, I think I am,
but how did you--
[LAUGHS]
And the contrast between
that and hitchhiking
was actually really
difficult. Because I'd
gone there in the past
and had this sense
of being kind of welcomed and
supported at the roadside.
I think something about
the bicycle appeals
to that US spirit
of bootstrapping.
They assume you're homeless.
It doesn't matter
that your bicycle is
made in a artisan bike factory
in the south of Germany,
or that your pannier bags
and your Brooks saddle
were made by craftsmen
in the Midlands
or elsewhere in Germany,
and it's collectively
worth a thousand or so pounds.
There's an assumption
that if you're
traveling the
States on a bicycle,
you're a homeless person.
But they think you're a
really good homeless person.
You're actually trying.
And it's kind of
ironic, because one
of the things I love
about travel by bike
is you're really independent.
It's a machine that keeps going.
It's rare that it would
have a mechanical that
would stop you from going.
And even if it was
a minor mechanical,
you can generally keep going.
So you can be independent.
Whereas when you're
actually standing
at the roadside waiting
for a ride, needing a ride,
you are entirely
reliant and dependent
upon the people passing you.
And whereas I'd had the ability
to keep going on a bicycle
myself, and nevertheless been
met with all of this help,
as a hitchhiker stuck in
the middle of a desert
waiting for someone
to pick you up
and being met with this
constant mistrust and fear,
it was a kind of war of
attrition a little bit.
And the determination required
to sort of not be worn down
by this constant
rejection that's going on
was actually one of the
most difficult things
about the journey.
I kind of will definitely cut
some slack to the US population
and the driver
population of the US.
I mean, Hunter S.
Thompson called
the US the kingdom of fear.
And much as I think there's an
awful lot of unjustified fear
in American society, American
popular culture, American news
stroke entertainment,
I do think, as I say,
there are a lot of
people on the interstates
and highways of the US who in
Europe would be either getting
professional help
or would simply not
be there because
migrating south for winter
is something that doesn't really
belong in the 21st century
wealthy nations.
But I sympathize with
the American population,
because yeah, it's a
hard place out there.
The interstate is in itself
its own kind of place.
This was just a
photo that I found
while I was pulling out the
other ones, but this was to--
in America they say--
air up your tires, which
was an interesting phrasology.
The first time I
asked on the bicycle,
can I pump up my tires,
and the guy said, you
want to air up your tires?
Yeah, that makes sense as well.
But yeah, putting
a dollar into it
to help feed children
elsewhere in the States.
And then these kind of thousands
of miles of empty highways.
And as I say, it's kind of a
culture all of its own, really.
With the highways, the
truck stops, and again,
the space in between, and
not a whole lot happening.
Because people are going
between rest areas.
And you just see these desert
stretches in the meantime.
And with truck drivers
who are counting
not in miles but in
hours, because they
say that if they were counting
miles, they'd go crazy
and they'd never get anywhere.
And I think of that as the
interstate is a little bit
like a monocrop in some ways.
In the way that we
mass agriculture,
you have a field where
they're growing the crop
and nothing else
grows within it,
because it's all about the crop.
Likewise on the interstates--
it's a car saturated culture.
And where it's sort of not
many signs of human life.
And especially as a
hitchhiker and occasionally
as a pedestrian walking
down the highways,
you really feel that
sense of deviance.
I would have been
picked off the highways
many times by state
troopers saying
that it's illegal to hitchhike
in the United States.
And other variants
of that, saying it's
illegal to hitchhike
in this state.
And variants again, saying
you can't hitchhike here,
but if you cross
the county line,
then you can
hitchhike all right.
It's not my turf.
So that kind of process
always interrupting you.
And "Interstate" won-- it
won an award for travel
book of the year last year.
I gave half of the
prize money to the ACLU.
A time when the Muslim ban
was just coming in in the US,
but largely, more than
anything, because the book was--
I was very conscious
in the number
of times I was pulled off of
highways by state troopers
or cops.
Although the
experience of it was
very aggressive,
was very forthright,
I'd be standing there,
and a car would pull in.
I'd sort of roll my eyes knowing
what was about to happen.
And then you'd get the
microphone on the roof,
the loudspeaker on the
roof would shriek at me
to go over to the crash barrier.
So I'd go lazily over
to the crash barrier
and lean on the crash barrier
and start unhooking my bag
straps from my shoulders.
And then it shrieks again,
like, don't move, stay there,
leave your pack on,
at which point, OK.
And then he comes out
and comes up to me
and asks if I'm armed,
which as a European,
it's an absolutely
crazy question ever
to be asked anyway.
And then he pats me down.
And we've seen-- we've all now
seen many images of black men,
generally men-- black
men and black people
shot dead by state troopers in
situations that I can really
relate to having been in.
And actually, my situation
being that bit more deviant--
I wasn't even sat at
the wheel of my own car.
But there's this
sense of the armor
of white skin, the
lack of prejudice that
came from law enforcement.
Although they were suspicious
of what I was doing,
they were, none the less,
willing to tolerate it.
Some of them even giving me a
lift to the edge of the county
line and taking me along
a little bit on my way.
And by the time I
got out of the car,
us having some kind
of conversation
and forming a bit
of a relationship.
And similarly, although
hitchhiking in the States
was often a case
of counting cars,
and sometimes you'd count 10,
and you'd get really lucky,
and you'd get another
ride after 10.
Sometimes you'd still
be counting after 200.
But I have no doubt whatsoever
that those numbers would
be a lot higher, especially in
certain parts of the country,
were I not white.
So there's an interesting
sort of intersection with race
at the roadsides in that way.
And the truck stop
is another kind
of insight on the US in itself.
And I spent a lot of my time
in truckstops going round
the rigs that were parked in.
Occasionally taking a
break and sitting down
and get myself a
coffee in the canteen.
And these places are generally
always known in the US
as a food desert, which
is a concept that I think
might be coming
to parts of Europe
as well, which
isn't a great thing.
But places where there
is no fresh produce,
there's no fresh
vegetables, and everything
that you can buy
to eat is packaged,
is made from refined flour or
refined sugar, which slowly
has a sort of gently
debilitating effect
on your sense of will
to go on, I think,
when you can't look forward to
your next meal at any point.
The other thing
about the truckstops
was how martial the culture was.
I remember being conscious
of this very military edge
to the stenciled
images that drivers
would put on their cabs.
I remember going down the
highway and one of them
next to me with a silhouetted
man with a rifle kneeling over
a fallen comrade.
And it says, we will
honor their sacrifice.
I remember walking into a shop,
and there's a big American flag
on the side of it
in a truck stop,
and saying, the
American flag does not
flutter with the wind but
the last breaths of all
who died for it.
Which is a really
intense thing when
you're just looking for some
orange juice or something.
But you kind of see this
massive sentimentality
and emotional investment placed
into the area of the truckstop.
Because you have guys
here that are driving,
well, as the adverts on the
back of some of the rigs
will attest, for a cent a mile.
Which is evidence, I think,
of both how crazily enormous
the US is but also
how incredibly poorly
paid truck drivers are.
I remember as well the truck
stop shops often had toys in,
which is unusual for this
population of slightly
surly adult men.
But they are, of course, often,
if not always, absent fathers.
Sometimes you'll see a
trucker with his dog.
Sometimes a trucker with
his dog and his wife.
Maybe sometimes his wife has
also got a trucker license,
and they share the wheel and go
back and forth across country.
But often, they are
just absent fathers away
from their families.
So you'd see the toys there as
you walk into the truck stop.
And again, this very
martial culture--
toy tanks, toy soldiers.
Again, because I feel
that on the roads
with this fairly
modern serf existence
of driving someone else's rig
just to stay afloat in America,
you need to feel that
you're part of something
bigger, that the cargo you're
moving corresponds somehow,
in a small way, to the American
dream that you're possibly
getting short sold
on but nevertheless
have to believe in.
Because if not, why
would you carry on?
There are also the more
interesting characters
at the truckstops.
And a lot of humanity
in amongst it as well.
My ride after Columbus, Ohio--
I would have hitchhiked down
towards Cincinnati, where
I got a really nice ride with--
it was a retired--
well, reluctantly
retired local radio DJ
who'd been put out of work
by automation, essentially.
Which is a theme of the book,
because in the old days,
he would have gone into
the studio for five days
of the week and spun records.
Now he only needs to go in for
two hours on a Monday morning
to say, next up is
Casey and the Waves,
and it's a good morning
here in Cincinnati,
because the rest of it can
all be put into a playlist.
So you've got this guy
who would have been--
and he said, I wouldn't
be able to sleep at night.
I was so excited about my job.
And I met him on a
Sunday, and he was just
going out for a drive
for something to do.
He took me down to a truck
stop outside of Cincinnati.
And there, eventually, I met--
I invested at that truck
stop for about a day of time
just walking between rigs.
Got offered a ride
by a Bosnian migrant
trucker who had a vehicle
recovery-- big vehicle recovery
rig.
And he was driving
down to Mississippi,
which wasn't quite on
my route to California,
but it would have taken
me a few hundred miles.
I thought I could get
a bit bigger than that,
and so I kept walking.
And eventually I
met Pala, who is
kind of the hero of the
book in loads of ways,
because we spent
five days together.
And we would have driven
from there in Cincinnati
back north towards
Lexington, Ohio,
to pick up 30,000 kilograms of
laminate wrapped plastic that
was going to be driven
down to Yuma, Arizona,
on the Mexico border,
where it would
be wrapping of
courgettes, or zucchinis,
coming over from Mexico.
It was produce.
So it was my 3,000
mile ride that
was going to get me most
of the way to California.
And so Pala was my
man sort of thing.
And we spent five
days or so together.
And those five days were
probably-- certainly
the easiest in terms
of moving miles,
but also in terms
of actually having
a kind of human
encounter were definitely
the easiest and the best
period within the entire trip.
Pala is from the Punjab
in north of India.
He's been 10 years in the
United States, approximately.
He kind of has to pay rent
to the bank on his cab,
on the cab of his truck.
But he, nevertheless, is in
the position where one day he
will own it, which is
unusual and very fortunate.
And he's very grateful
for that position.
And the fact that he
is in that position
is an evidence of the
diaspora of Punjabi community
in the USA.
He had a cousin who is an
architect in San Francisco who
makes good enough money
that he could sign
to be the guarantor on the
debt for his cab, which means
that Pala could one day make
his own money rather than just
being a servant of
a trucking company.
Nevertheless, there
are still these sort
of interesting
and intricate ways
by which he goes about
making a living in the US,
and staying healthy
in particular.
He's a Sikh, and thus a
vegetarian, which in the US
is probably not a bad way of
staying that bit healthier,
especially at truckstops.
And it was an incredible
experience for me
to be in the backwaters
of Missouri or Oklahoma
eating parathas, because Pala
would have been well in touch
with the Punjabi trucking
community that is dotted
across the roadsides of
the US, would have spoken
with a kind of grudging respect
for the Gujarati trucking
community, which he says
works that little bit harder
and a little bit smarter.
So they now own all
of the truck stops,
and the Punjabis just
drive the trucks.
But we would have been
there eating our parathas,
eating our dal and our thali
in New Mexico, in Indiana.
And just having this
fascinating insight
on a different
part of US culture.
And especially US road
culture, which is often
very forceful and inhuman,
and you're shut off
from a community there.
Because everyone's living
this isolated existence,
where they're just trying
to get from A to B.
And everything that
happens in between
is almost like an inconvenience.
And so for me and Pala to spend
those five days hanging out
was really valuable.
And I mean, some of
the things that he
would have talked about--
the one that always
stays with me,
or a couple that
stays with me most--
well, he remembered that
he'd voted for Obama in 2012.
But he wasn't sure if he'd
voted for the Republicans
or the Democrats,
which was, I thought,
really kind of nice
insight on what people
say about polarization.
Which is certainly an
issue in modern politics,
modern communication.
I found it really
striking that more
than the polarization
there, what you saw
was just a disconnect-- a
disconnection and an apathy
and a political system
that was completely
irrelevant from his
daily life on the roads.
The most endearing thing of Pala
was his love of field hockey.
And he would have talked about
as a child in the Punjab,
his mom having to ground
him or tell him off
because she found him practicing
his field hockey strokes late
at night in his bedroom.
And the best part of it
was that in modern America,
his survival regime involved
partly going back to the Punjab
for two months of every year
so that he could play field
hockey, and therefore stay
healthy because he couldn't
afford health insurance.
So he would get another cousin
to drive his rig on his behalf
for those two months.
He went home and played
field hockey to stay healthy.
There was one time
when I asked him,
I said to him as we went
by a tornado shelter, which
they have at the interstate
roadsides for when tornadoes
come through.
It was a shelter
in Texas that Pala
wanted to stop at and show
me because he loved it
because it was so quiet.
And as we were walking
back to the cab
and doing our stretches, having
had our five days of vegetarian
food in Oklahoma and Texas.
I was like, Pala, we must be
the healthiest guys in any truck
in the United States.
No, no, my cousin is a trucker.
He does 45 minutes of
yoga in his cab every day.
And again, that's the
sort of theme of the book
that I'd hoped comes through.
I think it has.
And this human, this
humanity, this human spirit
that's kind of wrapped inside
the metal capsule of a car
or of a truck, or of
the industrial economy
of modern nation, somewhere
on the highways of the US,
there is a Punjabi trucker
doing yoga stretches
behind those curtains.
And I always found that an
incredibly heartening thing.
And that's sort of
a migratory thing
as well, whether it's from
Punjabis coming from the Punjab
to work the US.
And speaking of the fact that
the Gujaratis have a head
start on them, because
every cousin of a newcomer
from Gujarat who is
already in the US
will put forward $10,000 so
that the next person in has
a $50,000 pot to start from.
All of these moments
of globalization,
which is actually, much as
it shouldn't be, as low pay
as it is, and it should be with
more rights and protections,
is globalization working
in the way that it should.
And also, with the trail
of plastic from Ohio--
recycled plastic going
from Ohio down to Arizona
to wrap courgettes that
have been grown in Mexico.
This sort of almost
invisible commerce
that underpins the
lunches that we
eat in the city and
the global supply
chain that we rely
on and can take
for granted in our daily lives.
You kind of see that
out on the roads.
And in all my books
and all my journeys,
that's kind of been
a theme as a result
of going less seen places.
From Arizona, Pala and I, we
would have gone Cincinnati down
into Mississippi.
My geography of this
journey has faded a little.
Down into Mississippi along
and across towards Texas
via Oklahoma, the top of
Texas, New Mexico, Arizona.
I got out of the cab at
Grand Canyon and Flagstaff,
walked and hitchhiked
a little bit further,
and then came to San Francisco.
And returning,
essentially, to that--
the bubble, if you like, from
New York City and Brooklyn
back to the mission
of San Francisco.
Although, again, I'd sort
of questioned to what extent
these places are bubbles,
certainly walking
through the Mission District
anytime after 8 o'clock
on an evening doesn't
feel much like a bubble.
And it seems there
every bit similar
to having visited refugee
camps in Calais or in Greece.
People that have been washed
up, destitute, from a society
that doesn't take them or
doesn't have space for them.
So yeah, I think that's
kind of a key thing.
Much as we think of
ourselves as disconnected
in cities, the victims or the
hardships of the modern city,
the modern economy are,
of course, all around us.
And I think I just
wanted to close, really,
on a note of what
the book is and what
the journey was in terms
of optimism or pessimism,
essentially.
And I think optimism is
an eternal US trait, which
is potentially
the one thing that
can save the country
from itself in some ways.
The fact that there's always
hope that we can improve this,
we can make it better,
we can fix this.
And the tone of the book
is very much one of America
is a hard place.
And it is, because you'll
meet a guy at a roadside who's
obviously got substance abuse
problems and has just told you
that he's gone and buried his
mom within minutes of meeting.
You'll pass signs near
prisons saying, do not pick up
hitchhikers, because 1% of
the United States population
is in jail.
And there's a kind of prison
industry economy attached
to that.
And so it is a very stark place.
I find it very disheartening
in lots of ways.
But there are the moments
within the journey
and within culture and
society, the meeting of Pala
and the guy who's just
working for his 10 years
before he can start
making his own money,
but has hope for the future, who
has a feeling that, actually, I
don't understand why
people in this world fight.
I just want to work.
I just want to make
a way for myself.
There is also that
threaded through the book
and threaded
through the journey.
And I think the
value of the journey
is something else that I always
like to draw attention to.
I kind of see the
world currently
as dividing very much
between flows and accounts.
And flows might be
flows of capital,
or flows of transit,
flows of people.
And the accounts are
the pocketed versions
of that that we make
for ourselves, that we
take security in.
In the internet, we have
the social media account
in amongst the flow
of information.
On the highways, you have
the automobile account,
where you're safe
and it's your place
in amongst the movement and all
of the life that swarms around
it.
And even in the cities, I
mean, I don't normally--
I used to be a cycle courier
and saw all of the cities
and spent a lot of time
just on the streets
looking at what was
going on around me.
And I think increasingly,
in a modern development
such as this one even, you see
the architecture is very much
done as if an account.
It's a controlled,
localized place
that is designed to
make one feel at home,
but often at the expense of that
random act of life or moment
or chance that you encounter
as a matter of course
when cycling between places or
when hitchhiking and opening
yourself to that
sense of possibility.
And obviously, being at
Google and working in Search,
again, that's a model
that often filters us
towards accounts that
we're comfortable with
and moves us away
from anything that we
think we might not like as a
result of past performance.
And I think it's always
important to question, what
are we losing to those moments?
What are we losing to that
reliance on a sense of security
and a desire for it and to
repeat the past in the future
that we build for ourselves?
So I think that's key to
the journey, hitchhiking,
and certainly all that I
write about and my projects.
And yeah, I hope that that
was an interesting reflection
on 5,000 miles across
the United States
in the age of Donald Trump.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: We do have
time for questions.
Please wait for the microphone.
AUDIENCE: I have a
couple of questions.
Let me just change
microphone there.
The first one, how does it
feel to be absolutely alone
on this chart or
on this journey?
So you're on your own.
You're alone.
Especially, how did
you keep yourself alive
being in like in the
middle of deserts
and counting up to
200 cars in one row?
JULIAN SAYARER:
Yeah, good question.
I mean, in terms
of being alone, I
think I've always just done
all right with that for one.
I don't know if I'm a
natural loner or something.
But yeah, I mean, I cycled
to Istanbul on my own
for the first time
when I was 20.
And kind of cycling through
the Alps and having no one
around was the first
time I started feeling,
actually, this is amazing,
and this is what I like.
I think writing
has actually always
been a great companion to me,
because much as the books are
true to life,
nevertheless you're
kind of creating a slightly
external view of what you're
doing when you're writing it
down, when you're recording it.
So it's not exactly a
diary, but it gives you
a sense of-- a space to reflect
and to converse with yourself,
if you like, via your notepad.
And then the States
and that sort
of physical issues of
going between empty space,
and especially in
cars or in a truck,
is comparatively easy
relative to cycling.
I mean, going through
the deserts of Central
Asia on a bicycle and
you've got 250 miles
to cycle between villages.
And maybe you'll get
to a caravan pulled
to the crossroads
in the middle of it,
where someone will be
selling some grilled meat.
But maybe you won't.
So yeah, in the States it was
comparatively simple for that,
just having some
water with me and--
yeah, the harder part
was finding something
that I wanted to actually
eat, to take for my pack lunch
kind of thing.
AUDIENCE: And you also
said that you'd like--
on the road with drivers
who talk with you openly,
so it was really easy to
make a sincere conversation.
How does it feel when here,
when most of human encounters
are usually smalltalk, but don't
actually care about each other?
JULIAN SAYARER: In
the city, you mean?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JULIAN SAYARER: Yeah,
it's really true.
Yeah, I think cities are
interesting environments
for me, or quite challenging
in some ways, especially a city
as developed and controlled
as London, essentially.
There's lots of very
high paid people here.
There's lots of companies
making a lot of money.
And so everyone has a very
sort of predetermined agenda
and route.
And I think that kind of
removes a lot of the opportunity
for chance encounter.
But they are still
there, and I think
you just have to appreciate
them when they come.
I mean, riding a bicycle is
essential to me in London,
and that small moment of
agreeing with someone,
even about the weather at
traffic lights, is great.
I had a brilliant moment a
couple of weeks back having
an electrical device repaired
at a shop in [INAUDIBLE],,
a guy who's been there forever.
And we were just
making small talk.
And it was Wednesday.
It was prime minister
questions time.
He had it on TV.
And a Tory backbencher had asked
a question about Christianity
and the importance of protecting
the world's Christians,
which of course, I'm
completely down with.
But I said I'd like if they
talked more about persecution
of Muslims as well.
I'm half Turkish,
and it's an issue
that Islamophobia in the
Tory party concerns me.
And I said that,
and he said that.
And then he said, it's like
paradise is a roundabout.
And we all are going
to the same roundabout,
just on different roads.
This is Allah's world.
And the Christian road
and the Muslim road, they
go to the same place.
And we're there with like
solder around and wires
hanging over the place in
this basement on Church Street
in [INAUDIBLE].
And the man is just
evangelizing to me
about the need for the world's
religions to kind of come
together and be as one.
And so it does happen.
I think independent businesses
are really good for it as well
as the way that we travel.
AUDIENCE: Do you have any photos
of yourself from the journey,
because you showed
the photos of places.
But like, it's interesting
how it doesn't look different.
JULIAN SAYARER:
Yeah, from that one,
I have a couple of
selfies from that one.
I look pretty grizzly.
From cycling around
the world, though, I
have a lot more because I
broke a world record for it
and Guinness wanted
ratification stuff.
So they wanted to see that I
was actually in those places.
And yeah, they must exist
somewhere on the internet.
AUDIENCE: Maybe I missed
this earlier, but--
so the book is about Emre.
Is that you as well?
JULIAN SAYARER: Yeah, so
Emre's my middle name.
And it's just a way of creating
a slight distance between--
I mean, it's what
happened to Julian,
but it's my written
persona in that book.
AUDIENCE: Do you find
that that sort of
helps you to think about it in
third person a little bit more?
JULIAN SAYARER: Yeah, slightly.
And I think when you're
putting something out
for public consumption,
it's kind of just nice to--
when it is your life.
And there are elements in
there that are personal.
So it's just kind
of wanting to create
that sort of small buffer.
But yeah, it's
definitely a good point.
My publisher had a couple of
things to say about it as well.
AUDIENCE: How much
of the book did you
write when you were on the
road as opposed to later on,
and how were you writing
it, like laptop, phone?
JULIAN SAYARER: Yeah, I always
write in a notepad really.
I don't think I've ever
traveled with a laptop.
And I was just scribbling
down in my notepad.
And generally, I must have
written about half of it
while I was out on the road.
I mean, occasionally
with Pala in his truck
talking about his life and daily
life in the truck or trucker
community, occasionally I'd
just start scribbling down.
Oh, you can't put
this in a book.
So I'd make my note there.
Occasionally, though,
it's just really--
I'm profoundly impacted
by what would happen.
And my penultimate
ride was a guy
in the Central Valley of
California, a very depressed
agricultural community.
And he couldn't take me
as far as he wanted to
because he was on parole,
and it would violate
the terms of his parole.
He was a guy that
told me that he
doesn't keep many friends
because they get him
into trouble.
Which was just such a
profoundly sad thing
to be told by
another human being.
So things like that, I
would have just been--
I would have finished the
ride, and I'd just make time
to write always, really.
Just because it's-- it becomes
a way of processing after
a while.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
You mentioned that you are
also a cycle courier in London,
I guess.
So what kind of
memorable experiences
do you make in this
role, rather than--
I guess it's very different.
JULIAN SAYARER: Yeah, I mean, it
has a similar kind of quality.
There's some element
of being a human cog
in a mechanical
machine when I think
you're traveling in that way.
I think it's a big part on
the bicycle or hitchhiking.
I mean, memorable moments
as a courier, 2008
in the financial crisis, and
riding from the EC2 Square Mile
out to Canary Wharf
to Lehman Brothers
to deliver receivership
notices worth $33 billion
and getting paid 2 pound
50 for each delivery
was a very interesting
perspective on a collapse
of the world economy.
Or equally taking
bouquets of flowers
from hedge funds in
Mayfair to brothels.
So it's kind of, yeah--
like the first book,
"Life Cycles" is sort of--
I saw it as globalization
at the roadsides.
And then "Messengers"
was the second book.
And that, to me, was the
globalized city sort of thing.
So there's always, yeah, humans
looking at modernity kind
of thing going on, hopefully.
AUDIENCE: Can I ask a quick
question as another cyclist,
then?
Well, do you still
cycle around London?
And what's your opinion of cycle
lanes and facilities in London?
And if you could change one
thing, what would that be?
JULIAN SAYARER: That's
a good question.
Yeah, I'm definitely still a
cyclist anywhere I go, really.
It's just my way of travel,
including in London.
I cycled down to Victoria
yesterday and went along
the embankment, which is now,
as you've probably mostly seen,
this nice wide segregated
cycle path that only got put
in a few years ago.
And I just-- yeah, it
gives me a great optimism
that there are so many more
people visibly getting around
on bikes.
And actually, the
architecture of the city
is changing to reflect that.
There was a great moment
by Waterloo Bridge
a couple of years back when
that cycle route had first
been put in.
And there's actually
a wider pavement
also that separates that cycle
track from where the road is
and where the traffic is.
And that wider pavement
would have been a lane
of traffic three years ago.
And I remember seeing
an old couple--
and it's always nice seeing old
couples being romantic together
anyway, but they were having
a prolonged goodbye and a kiss
goodbye on that
bit of former road
that is now a wide pavement.
And it was just--
I remember looking at it and
thinking, wow, two years ago
that space exactly there
was just a line of smoking,
gnarling, impatient traffic.
And now it's actually a place
that humans can actually
stand and be as humans.
And so I think that
is increasingly
the culture of the modern city.
And cars have less
and less place in it,
which I think is
a positive trend.
And I hope that London can carry
on progressing, with any luck.
AUDIENCE: At the start,
you mentioned about your
around the world
cycling record, and you
felt the whole process of
around the world cycling
had become very commercialized
and been somewhat devalued
by all the sponsorship into it.
And I think that's
probably a trend that's
continued since then as well.
How did you feel as you
went through that process
and completed it,
like the fact that you
were during the
Guinness attributions
or getting the proof of that,
and going through the Guinness
presence?
Did that feel quite
commercialized anyway,
or did you feel
like you achieved
what you wanted that that?
JULIAN SAYARER: No, really
good, perceptive question.
And absolutely, when I was--
things like making notes on my
daily log and stuff like that
seemed fine.
My mile-- my start point and
my finish point, all of that
was fine.
But yeah, taking
a photo of myself
with a redwood and
things like that.
And the redwoods in particular
are quite an interesting place
to ride, through the redwood
forest in Northern California.
You're there with
a tree that started
growing at the time
of the Roman Empire.
And it's still growing.
And you're on this silly six
month quest to break a record
when you're not really
a competitive person--
apparently not a
competitive person.
Yeah, so it was a bit strange.
And it's kind of a
mixture of necessity
and just seeing it through,
really, in the end.
I really hadn't liked
the corporate approach.
It misrepresented it in
terms of the meaning of life
on the open road
as something that
was for sale to banks
and investment funds,
but also misrepresented
it as something
that was this unpleasant alpha
male man against the world
thing, where time
and again, it's
the world that actually
helps you along.
And so I wanted to show that
it could be done differently.
And actually, it
was a lot of fun
that it wasn't as hard as
it had been made to look
or as unpleasant at
all as an experience.
And then halfway
through, I'd been
a courier in London anyway, so
I was going off funds of that.
And so come the
midpoint, I needed
to finish because I was going
to run out of money anyway.
So there's always
that wolf at the door
to make sure you keep going.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you
again, Julian Sayarer.
[APPLAUSE]